(laughing)
(upbeat music)
- I think I only go to
7 Eleven on road trips.
- They've got these little
brownie cookie things
that are real good.
- 7 Eleven has pretty good food.
- I feel like Japanese people
just really know how to up the anty.
- Yes.
- Like there vending machines
are like really cool over there.
I'm sure they'll like
make 7 Eleven amazing.
- Oh.
What is this?
- Green chips.
- There's a nice dust on here.
I love the dust.
You can't see the dust
but there's a great dust.
(speaking foreign language)
- I would love to sit down
with just a bag of these
and a movie.
- Tortilla chips kind of like taste like
you need to have some sort of dip
but these edamame chips I could just eat
a whole bag on it's own.
- Honestly, any sort of wrapped
baked good is always good.
Little Debbie.
- It's gonna be so good, oh yeah.
- This is the smoothest
doughnut I've ever ...
Holy shit.
- This doughnut is lubed up.
- I didn't say it was lubed.
(laughing)
- No.
- Much drier than I thought it would be.
- It's like cardboard.
- This was either made in
30 seconds very hastefully
or it was made 90 years ago.
I'm not really sure which one it is.
- Sugar Butter Sand tree.
- Well this is great from the get go
because it looks like
something I haven't had.
- Oh my God, that smells delightful.
- They're really hard to bite into.
- Mouth feel was not great.
- Mouth feel's not great
but then that frosting starts to mix
with the tree bark part of it
and turns into this wonderful
little cacophony and sweet.
- What?
We got a little, uh-oh.
We got scabs.
- Oh plum.
- Plums, oh my God old
Asian people love plum.
- It's so sour.
Awe Nelly.
- Oh man.
It changes.
Oh, it's evolving in my mouth.
This is great.
This is a symphony of flavor.
I like it.
- I ate too many.
- Every time I've had this ...
- It's so sour.
It's so good.
- That is the most sour
thing I ever had in my life.
- This looks like it was
made in five seconds.
- They're literally raisins in there.
It's not just like a
raisin flavored thing.
There's literally just
little raisins in it.
Is this like a Japanese ant on a log?
- Is there alcohol in this?
- [Man] It's rum raisin.
- This is how kids learn to drink.
You just feed them one of
these rum raisin sandwiches
and you're good to go.
- I didn't feel like we
got the best of Japan.
- Overall, I thought
there was a wide variety
of things here.
- I'm very impressed with
like Japanese 7 Eleven.
- I'm gonna call all sandwiches sand now
because that's how the
cool kids in Japan do it.
- Yeah, who needs wich
and you can just say sand.
- Hey, let's get some turkeysand.
- Yeah, all about that sandlove.
(laughing)
(upbeat music)